[Music]
[Music]
good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster and today new
questions with more sleaze allegations
front and center of the newspapers we're
joined today by the transport secretary
grant chaps
and the shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy plus
the former prime minister gordon brown
will also join us
a little bit later on this hour also
coming up
digital passport wallet and watch with
spain ready to welcome british tourists
back in june
we'll talk to portugal's ambassador to
the uk about when the country plans to
open
its stores and
so great britain is the person that
you're falling for telling the truth
oh my god that's her this is actually
massive or hiding behind their lives
swipe left we speak to the hosts of
catfish uk about the perils of
online dating it's wednesday the 28th of
april
sky news witnesses pressure on cremation
services in india and questions the
accuracy of official statistics
as covert deaths past 200 000.
just tell me how many what's the problem
with telling me how many just tell me
how many have you registered today
how many debts
come clean labor demands answers as more
reports emerge
around the renovation of the prime
minister's flat
a shot in the arm a new study finds a
single dose of covid19 vaccines
can cut transmission of the virus by up
to half
[Music]
singing to stay well queen's brian may
talks to sky news about the mental
health challenges
of the pandemic i have times when i
think you know life is actually
over and i can't do anything that i need
to do you feel like a caged animal
i'm a terrible mother terrible wife
slightly above average actress
and tv bafta hopefuls will reveal
this year's nominations and go through
the likely winners
with caitlin moran
it's been the frostiest april on record
and the month will close on a chilly
note as well
at last some range to talk about i'll
have more details in about half an hour
well very good morning to you we're
starting with concerns that the true
number of people
dying from covid19 in india is being
under-reported as the official number of
people who've lost their lives passes
200 000
sky news has been to delhi where we've
seen crematoria being extended to deal
with demand
in the last 24-hour period india has
reported a record
362 757 new cases
a further 3293 people have died in the
country
over the last 24 hours that takes the
official number of deaths to 201
1187 a warning that this report from our
special correspondent alex crawford
starts on pictures of body bags at a
makeshift crematorium
and contains images that you may find
distressing
from the start
so many families are suffering so many
coronavare's deaths
but amidst the grief there's growing
anger and a building doubt
that the reality doesn't match the
official death figures
this small crematorium in east delhi is
working all hours to keep up
the pyres are close together to try to
fit in as many as possible
and when we visited we counted at least
30
active pyres several ambulances
arrived with more bodies this alone from
one private hospital brought
five dead in one door another ambulance
driver
from a separate hospital told us he'd
been driving all day long
i bring about 10 to 12 bodies every day
he tells us
many of the relatives said they waited
hours to get a funeral space
and they're convinced the tally of
covert deaths is far
higher than being admitted the league
government
says that 380 people are dying every day
from corona
but it's actually around one thousand
more than one thousand
what do you base that on how do you know
we know we know because we we you know
we visit
many hospitals with our patients there
is no beds
available and in criminal area
we search two or three but they are no
space
then finally we came here
and we are waiting from the last two or
three hours
to get a space yes to get this piece
yeah
they're so busy the crematorium's being
extended
with another 100 spaces
the biggest growing industry right now
with most shops closed
in the lockdown seems to be the
graveyard business
they told us there's a steady stream of
funerals throughout the day
so many people are dying and brought
here he says daily at least 250 to 300
bodies are brought here we see it
all the deaths are meant to be logged
with the funeral officials
so we inquired about the daily figures
just tell me how many yeah what's the
problem between me how many just tell me
how many have you registered today
how many deaths how many yeah
how many applicants the answer didn't
even match what we'd seen that hour
20 20 today even being conservative
the figures are double
and that's just in this crematorium with
18 other
official sites in the capital many of
the relatives are deeply suspicious
80 of the debts are due to the medical
negligence here
what i have i have realized we could
have saved them
but they were in hospital they did not
get the proper care what they wanted
and because of the lack of the oxygen
lack of the medicines lack of
injections people are dying here
in neighboring states too there seems
certain discrepancies about the death
statistics
our researchers in uttar pradesh counted
at least 25 bodies waiting for funerals
and about eight lit in gaziabad and a
lot of angry relatives frustrated at the
process
the official insisted they had an
average of six
deaths and when our researcher
questioned this he was told they'd been
instructed to give that low number
by higher authorities the indian
government insists
all figures are being faithfully
recorded without
interference how many of these deaths
could have been avoided
if different decisions had been taken
alex crawford sky news
in new delhi let's talk to the transport
secretary grant shaps good to see you
this morning look
in in terms of india in real terms
what are we as a country doing to help i
suppose one of the biggest things
that we've done in response to those
heartbreaking uh
images um is to have been the country to
develop
um to research and developed and then
produce the
uh the the vaccine that we all know is
the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine but they use in
india i think under the name covey
shield
and that of course has been um produced
and licensed by astrazeneca
without them making any profit at all uh
as a sort of
service to humankind and
that will be making some kind of
difference now
india is a very large country they have
vaccinated 120 million people so far
but the scenes are just horrific and
it's a reminder
that actually kovid is still raging
around the world i was just looking at
the latest figures that peaked at 820
000 in the last seven day rolling
average that's the highest we've seen so
although we're
getting on top of it in the uk elsewhere
the numbers are huge and
britain's been sending out uh uh
equipment including equipment which
helps to make the
oxygen from from air which is obviously
one of the big shortages in india right
now
yeah i mean look in terms of vaccine
procurement we know it's a it's a bit of
a complicated story but i mean the
united states are sending vaccines to
india we're buying them from india
at the moment we understand what we've
ordered five million i mean
with the country on its knees is is that
the right course of action
yeah well that's why i mentioned that um
actually thanks to the oxford
research and astrazeneca's approach and
the way that this has been licensed
uh unlike for example with other uh very
successful vaccines like
pfizer which are made for profit um the
astrazeneca one
and in india under the name cover shield
uh is being made without profit and
i guess in terms of assistance uh and
being able to roll out large numbers
uh that's probably way bigger than any
other country's
contribution to india because it's
simply something which wouldn't exist
without this country
having invested in the r d and then made
the decision to do it
on a non-commercial basis so i think
that will all help of course there's
lots of other aid
and assistance being provided as well uh
including hundreds of pieces of
equipment and very importantly
the ability to actually make uh the the
vital oxygen which is
so missing from their uh hospital supply
right now
so not oxygen itself but actually um uh
the
the uh materials some called um uh
oxygen concentrators uh which are used
to create the oxygen so it doesn't then
run out
um look sticking with a covid situation
where are we in terms of of
international travel
this summer you know spain says it wants
us back
in june uh greece yesterday saying
they understand there could be some sort
of of a vaccination
certification from the uk coming in
pretty soon portugal we know
wants us back where are we what's
happening
yes of course both ways around the
countries that are keen to have
um are taurus back such the ones you
mentioned
and of course people are desperate to
take a break actually more than people
taking holidays i'm concerned to be able
to
rejoin families who you know may not
have seen each other for
for months or longer and that requires
travel
um having said that we need to be very
cautious i just mentioned that beyond
our shores we're seeing the highest
levels of coronavirus that we have seen
so far in the entire pandemic right now
so we do need to make sure that we do
this very very carefully we don't want
to throw away
the lock down we don't want to throw
away our remarkable roll out
in this country of the vaccination but
um
next in the next couple of weeks i'll
come back on and i'll be able to tell
you about which countries will have made
it into
uh the traffic light system and that
green list in particular
are the countries where you'll be able
to go to without needing to quarantine
on your
return you will still need to take a
pre-departure test and one test on your
return
i think people are getting very used to
testing now not least because
we provide testing uh up to twice a week
for
everyone in the country right now and so
i don't think a test itself is a big
deal
ideally countries will be on the list
where they don't need to
go people don't need to quarantine on
return but i can't give you that list
today because we don't have that
information yet
from the joint biosecurity center how
forgive me but how reliant is that going
to be on vaccine passports when are they
going to come in
yeah so there'll be four factors
actually that we'll be looking at so
when we look at a country we'll be
looking at their rates of
vaccination we'll also want to look at
the obviously the rates of coronavirus
in that country
um how many concerns there are about
variations
mutations of the virus in that
particular place and how accurate
we just saw in that india report how
accurate uh we believe the reporting to
be which is absolutely essential
we sort of take it for granted in this
country the reporting will be
accurate and run independently in our
case by the office of national
statistics but that isn't the case
everywhere we need to be able to always
see that information
so those are the factors and then in
terms of vaccine certification
i can confirm we are working uh on an
nhs
uh application actually it will be the
actual app
it will be the the nhs app that is used
um for people when they
book appointments with the nhs and so on
uh to be able to
show that you've had a vaccine or that
you've had testing
and i'm working internationally with
partners across the world
to make sure that that system can be
internationally recognized
so that's the way forward and actually
i'm chairing a meeting of the g7
uh secretaries of state for the
transport my equivalent from
america and canada and all the other g7
countries
next week on exactly the subjects i mean
in terms of
of the traffic light system have you got
a date when you're going to be making
that announcement what time table are
you working to
ah well the earliest possible unlock is
the 17th of may so stage three of the
unlocked so that we won't have
international travel before that and
we've said that will be the earliest
date i have to say so far
the data does continue to look good from
a uk perspective notwithstanding those
concerns
about where people might be traveling to
and making sure that we're protected
uh from the disease being re-imported
but specifically on when i'll be able to
say more about it i haven't been able to
do it
a long time in advance because of course
the situation changes
the whole time with this pandemic uh but
towards the beginning of may i will um
set out
which countries fall into the various
different um categories so
so not not long to wait now within the
next couple of weeks okay
look uh sleaze allegations all over the
papers
yet again this isn't going anywhere not
yet anyway we need some
some real clarity don't we as to what's
been going on
well i i hear um some of these claims
made and in particular i hear the
opposition trying to stir it up
um and i do wonder whether it's because
they haven't actually had much to
say about the main issues of the day
people talk about what did the prime
minister say in these meetings i'll tell
you what i never heard him
make any of those comments what i did
hear the prime minister say
during this pandemic was um the speed of
rollout of the vaccination program being
proposed
wasn't fast enough and he sent us and
officials back to the drawing board when
we
came back with a proposed program for
the vaccine rollout
he set us back again because he still
thought it could be faster and as a
result
of the prime minister's leadership what
we've ended up with is one of the
world's fastest vaccine rollouts and you
could say the same of
our ability to test which doesn't exist
elsewhere
or our ability to genome sequence uh the
coronavirus of which we do
around half the entire world's genome
sequencing and those
are things that have happened because of
the prime minister's determination
and things i've heard him say in
meetings are the things which have got
this country to this recovery so i'm
afraid
i think there's a fair amount of the
opposition uh
not wanting to talk about the success of
things like the vaccine program and
instead
throwing all these accusations around
forgetting perhaps that
you know new labour spent what was it
four hundred thousand pounds on
uh number ten refurbishments um uh i
think under under blair
uh and uh and and for some reason now
that you know if number 10 is
refurbished which has to be
at some point done because it's a
working building as well as a home
uh they're trying to just kick up all
this innuendo
forgive me in terms of the money we're
not talking about refurbing
the the sort of public areas of number
10 alba or number 11 in this case it's
it's the the you know the flat itself
for the prime minister
and his fiance now
did he get a loan from cchq i mean that
seems to be a pretty basic question that
no one can actually tell us at the
moment
well fortunately i think you you will
get the answer to all of that in two
ways first of all the cabinet secretary
uh is actually undertaking a quick
review and he's going to be able to
actually
set out what advice was given what order
everything happened in and i'm sure
he'll be able to clear all that up
secondly the cabinet office annual
reports and accounts report all the
disinformation and thirdly
the prime minister has already paid for
it so this seems to me to be
a bit of a sort of circular debate no
matter what said
the opposition are going to say oh no we
we don't believe it and i have to say
steve i do wonder whether it's just
because they don't want to talk about
um the success of uh the the vaccine
program our ability to
carry out coronavirus tests all the
things which have directly
led from the prime minister's leadership
this last few months and
uh i i don't know why they're so
obsessed
about this issue and the prime
minister's already said that he's paid
uh 100 for the refurbishments of the
number 10 flat
look can we just uh look forward towards
the end of this year a little bit
because i know you're you're keen to get
um
self-driving cars in essence on our
on our roads now look technologically
it's important
economically and ecologically it could
be important but is it safe yes it will
be
safer than people driving and if it's
not then we
won't do it is the answer and i just
want to reassure people i've seen one
two
of the headlines today this isn't about
the kind of cars that are already
available this isn't about a
self-driving tesla
or something those would not qualify uh
currently
for um full self-driving capability
uh instead this is about new technology
new types of cars which would mean that
for example
in the uk we have about 17 or 1800 road
deaths
a year it's come down over the years
since the 90s it's come down and down
and down and then plateaued
at about 17 to 1800 deaths a year
and 85 of those deaths are driver errors
so they their deaths come from primarily
uh errors made by human beings because
we're all human and i just think if
we're going to ever
drive that down lower and we can't turn
our back on technology
and not only that the uk is ambitious
and we want to be
one of the first countries to deploy
technology that will help save lives so
that that's what this is uh
about and as you say you could also cut
emissions
uh be a a fantastic
approach towards easing congestion for a
whole variety of
reasons but also critically uh be safer
and and save lives grand chaps good to
talk to you thank you
thank you okay let's talk to our
political correspondent kate mccann
what do you think kate we got a bit more
information there on international
travel and how things might start to
look in terms of holidays from the
transport secretary particularly around
the idea of a vaccine passport it's been
something that's been discussed at
length
we've heard actually from foreign
leaders talking about those discussions
maybe a bit more openly actually than
the uk government has so far
grant chap's confirming what we thought
was going to happen that the app that we
all use at the moment the nhs tracking
app that will become
the vaccine passport app we'll expect
more detail after that g7 meeting about
how exactly that's going to work but it
will be an internationally recognized
system
and as the transport secretary said
already people do have to test before
travel
of course travel is banned at the moment
so there will be some tweaks to that but
it's interesting to hear him start to
talk about the potential
for us all to go on holiday which would
be quite nice over the summer
and of course you did touch on those
allegations about the refurbishment of
the flat you could clearly see there
grant shot's trying to deflect away
talking about how the opposition doesn't
want to focus on the issues that the
government has got right
but i think at prime minister's
questions today boris johnson will find
it very difficult to avoid those
questions from shakir stanley
yeah indeed kate thank you
now a single dose of certain covid19
vaccines can cut
transmission of the virus by almost half
that's according to a new study
by public health england let's talk to
our reporter
aisha hazet who's in the newsroom for us
this morning and
it's interesting isn't it aisha if
you're there
let's get you in the wall
absolutely the these this finding
really highlights the fact that the
vaccination program could be the key
part
in helping bring the pandemic under
control now the research done
by public health england looked at both
the fisa biontech vaccine as well as the
oxford
they were looking at people who
contracted coronavirus up to three weeks
after receiving the first dose
of their vaccine and what they found was
that transmissibility
reduced by 38 to 49
across households and they expect
findings to be similar
for people living in shared
accommodations and and
prisons as well now protection was best
after 14 days from receiving the first
dose
and it was similar for people across
various age groups as well now
we've seen lots of other studies show
that these vaccines really do help slash
infection rates and the rates of
hospital
hospitalization so the next step the
experts want to take and look into is
whether
two doses can help reduce transmission
even more
okay aisha thank you well let's have a
look at the latest covert 19 figures
for the uk for you the latest government
figures show another 90
695 people have had their first
vaccination
304 688 have had their second
that means more than 47 million
injections have been given out
across the uk meanwhile there have been
2
685 new cases of corona virus reported
that's an increase of 161
on last tuesday or yesterday we should
say really shouldn't we 17 more deaths
have been reported as well
the total number of people who've died
due to the virus
is now 127 451.
now still to come this morning at
quarter to eight we're going to be
talking to former prime minister gordon
brown
to discuss how internet access can be
improved for young people
in terms of their education and at 20
past eight will talk to portugal's
ambassador
to the uk for more on vaccine passports
and the prospect
of a summer holiday this year
and tackling the stigma around hiv we'll
talk to the wales
rugby legend gareth thomas he'll tell us
why he thinks more needs to be done to
educate people
about the reality of living with hiv
that sort of quarter tonight
now looking at some of the other stories
for you this morning
and u.s health chiefs have said fully
vaccinated americans do not need to wear
masks
outdoors anymore unless they're in a big
crowd of strangers
the centers for disease control and
prevention released updated guidance
last night which added that there were
some cases in which
unvaccinated people could also go
without a face covering in certain
outdoor settings
dr rochelle walensky explained why the
cdc
had made the change
a u.s serial killer known as the torso
killer has admitted to murdering two
teenage girls in 1974.
richard cottingham pleaded guilty to
killing 17 year old maryam pryor
and 16 year old lorraine marie kelly
in august 47 years ago the 74 year old
has claimed responsibility for almost
100 murders
since he was imprisoned in 1981. arlene
foster's future as dup
leader and northern ireland's first
minister is under threat after a
rebellion within her own party
the dup leader appears to have lost the
support of the majority of the party in
the stormwater assembly
but insists she has bigger priorities
stories on leadership come up from time
to time and
it's one of those times so we'll just
deal with it and move on because i have
bigger things to do
including getting us through this covert
pandemic including
listening to the concerns of
working-class communities
britney spears will address a court in
her long-running battle with her father
today
jamie spears has been guardian of the
pop singer's
financial affairs since 2008 the
conservatorship allows mr spears to
control his daughter's estate
alongside a wealth management company
despite her request for him
to be removed from the role it's not
been confirmed which
issues spears wants to raise during her
appearance
with the status hearing set for the 23rd
of june
uh just a reminder that you can catch up
on the day's big business news and
interviews on the ian king business
podcast which is available on the sky
news app
or wherever you download your podcasts
now there are calls for more
face-to-face therapy to help people with
mental health problems as we
come out of lockdown sky news has spoken
to the queen guitarist the legend that
is brian may
who shared his own experience of how it
feels to live in his words
like a caged animal without the
appropriate support
salvia chowdhury reports i had some very
dark times you know i have times when i
i think you know life is actually over
and i can't do anything that i
need to do you feel like a caged animal
dr brian may from queen calls himself a
depressive
the rock legend says he struggled
mentally before and during the pandemic
his first panic attack was while on tour
with queen
one of the things i do is an acoustic
thing i do love in my life
and i started strumming away but i was
feeling something completely different i
was trying to do the job
but in my head i was panicking i was i
was in this horrible place i could feel
it
not just in my head but in my stomach it
was like it took hold of my whole body
he's supporting mental health charity
mind and their call for greater
face-to-face therapy
as the uk phases out of lockdown
that sense of panic was much deeper for
katie yelland
in march 2020 she attempted to take her
own life face-to-face therapy was off
limits to her because of the first
national lockdown
the virtual calls just weren't enough i
could sit there on a phone and i can fob
you off because i've done it
10 million times before i know exactly
what you want to hear what boxes that
you need ticked
what wasn't being seen was how badly i
was deteriorating
new research from mine shows the mental
health of one in four people
deteriorated during the pandemic
as a result of remote therapy more than
60 percent of those surveyed said
face-to-face services would have been
far more helpful so they're calling on
the government and the nhs to be more
inclusive in their approach as we ease
out of lockdown
so that way those receiving help can
make their own choices
about what works best for them
brian's experience during the past year
inspired him and singer and west end
star kerry ellis
to rework one of their old hits
[Music]
covid edition
the song called panic attack may have
its roots in a dark place
but its message is one of lights
it gives people a reality of what has
been going on but
there is a there is a way of hope there
is a root out of this that it is going
to be all right
[Music]
supper chowdery sky news
kerry ellis always puts a swelling first
she's a lovely
lady i have to say but now if you've
been affected by any of the issues that
we were talking about there
then the samaritans are available for
you 24
7. they'll listen to you without any
judgment at all
you can just talk to them plain and
simple it's a free phone number 116123
or if you'd rather email it's joe at
samaritans.org
now let's see what the weather's going
to do for you today
uh isabella's standing but i have to say
it threw it down around my house
yesterday isabelle and it was wet this
morning
yeah i mean at last it's been such a dry
month so at last some rain to talk about
and we desperately need it
let's take a look at where it's falling
and what we've got in store for the next
few days
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so we've got low pressure that's
gradually been tracking south across the
country which has been bringing
some heavy rain in places some thundery
activity as well
particularly at the moment for example
close to the dorset coast this low
continuing to trigger bursts of rain
today across the south and west
gradually migrating towards the
southeast later today otherwise
it's a bright quite chilly picture with
scattered showers but also some decent
sunshine i should think a good portion
of northern ireland and south and west
scotland will miss the showers and see
some sunshine but the north and east
will see a scattering of showers
possibly
with some hail maybe a bit of snow over
the hills you can see it's quite cold
air
only eight in edinburgh nine for
newcastle come south it's cooler as well
particularly where you have this rain
and as i said not well not everywhere
getting the heavy rain but there will be
bursts of heavy rain around
and that'll tend to track down into the
southeast as we head through the day
and overnight tonight and then pull away
that'll leave us with a clear starry
night tonight with a patchy frost
and tomorrow one of those typical april
days with sunshine
to begin with the shower clouds bubble
up and then there will be a few showers
in many areas i think through the course
of the day possibly a little bit wintery
chilly as well temperatures of 8 to 12
and after a widespread frost
on thursday night friday looks as though
it'll be fine to begin with and again
we'll see some showers gathering and
that's really how it looks
as we head into the bank holiday weekend
as well some frosty starts but by day
i think it should be largely fine just a
few showers scattered around
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabel thank you still to come this
morning we're going to be talking about
a new report showing the extent of
violence against women
with the director of the group victim
focus
there are things we all take for granted
as the rivers and tides flow
the sun will rise the wind will blow
and the earth will spin but are we now
spiraling into a climate crisis
which cannot be avoided no one can
predict the impact that it's going to
have
close to the peak here this is really
the moment it's true
expected to be hit very hard indeed what
can be done
to reverse the spiral the daily climate
show on sky news
will look for the answers
you know i love a challenge clearly and
you can see from the state of me as well
uh we only had another baby
four weeks ago so not only have i
um taken on an extra child i was taking
on this this mammoth challenge
of attempting in 10 months to go from or
being retired for the last three years
to trying to make a a winter olympic
game to not only make the winter olympic
games
the plan is to try and and obviously win
a medal
i i don't go into anything just to to
sort of do anything by half so the idea
is by going i want to do
it well and i want to try and uh achieve
another olympic medal so
um this all basically stems from a good
friend of mine a girl called kaylee
humphreys who's probably the most
successful
female bobsled of all time she's a
canadian now competing for america
um and she came across and just said
look
you should give it a go i've seen you've
been training she'd been badgering me
back in about 2014
15 to try and always say no no i'm a
long jumper um
but we've had all this time to to sort
of twiddle our thumbs i guess
if you like and and been sort of stuck
not being able to do an awful lot so it
just got me thinking well why not try
i reached out to the british team they
they sort of welcomed me
with open arms and and here we are so
the aim will now be
to to make the beijing winter olympics
uh and
and try and go for a medal so so there's
only one person
in the history of the world an american
who managed to win
a winter olympic and a summer olympic
gold medal
that was with boxing and bobsleigh so
nobody's ever managed to successfully do
it from athletics
and there's been a lot of crossover but
nobody's ever won in both
and and that's my plan i want to try and
be the first
first track and field athlete to ever
make the the change over
and actually and actually win and that
would be an amazing thing nobody in
europe's ever done it
it's a big challenge but i'm i feel
ready
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
safety rage what's the day podcast for
the ones who want to know more welcome
to the all-out politics podcast
for the story listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free now in the last few minutes the
transport secretary grant shaps has
confirmed to us here at sky news that
the nhs app
will be adapted to indicate whether a
person has been vaccinated
or had a recent negative covid test
we are working on an nhs
application actually it will be the
actual app it will be
the nhs app that is used um for people
when they
book appointments with the nhs and so on
uh to be able to
show that you've had a vaccine or that
you've had testing
and i'm working internationally with
partners across the world
uh to make sure that that system can be
internationally
recognized so that's the way forward and
actually i'm chairing a meeting
of the g7 uh secretaries of state for
for transport my equivalent from
uh america and canada and all the other
g7 countries
next week on exactly the subjects
so the importance of that of course is
it would in effect become
a vaccination passport and if it is
recognized by other countries then that
would help us travel
abroad in the summer when all this is
allowed
so it's an important step forward now
violence
against women and girls has been
highlighted in recent weeks and months
after the disappearance and murder of
sarah everard
now a new poll and it's it's a big one
it's more than 20 000 women
has found that 99.7
of all women have been subjected to
violence once
or more often including assaults
harassment
and rape well dr jessica taylor who's
the director of victim focus
which has created that report joins us
now it's good to see you this morning
are we reading this right 99.7
yep absolutely i think it is
the kind of statistic that um
we were expecting it to be that high
um and there is a possibility that all
of the previous statistics that you know
sit this type of violence set one in
three one and four one in five or even
larger some reports put one in ten one
in twenty
um could potentially be down to
methodological flaws that
we have managed to uh address
in this study which is why it's a lot
higher
so what have you addressed why why is
this a more reliable figure
so one of the things that we have
learned
in this type of research over the last
couple of decades is that when you
ask anybody really in the general
population this applies to children and
adults men and women
if you ask them questions that use
professional terminology like have you
ever been subjected to sexual violence
have you ever
experienced domestic violence those
types of questions
generally people don't necessarily
connect to them they don't relate to
them they don't see themselves as ever
you know having been subjected to those
things so they could they'll
they'll take no on a study like that
so there was a study um in sweden
um many years ago now probably about 15
years ago
that wanted to explore the same thing
but with children and actually found
that when you talk in specifics rather
than asking children
have you ever been abused by your
parents they ask things like you know
have your parents ever hit you in the
face have they ever kicked you if they
have a spat at you if they ever choked
you if they ever threatened to kill you
and from that study they found that
their data was a lot more accurate
because children
understood the specific events but
didn't necessarily know what child abuse
was
so i wanted to test that with
you know this sample with women and
girls and instead of asking women and
girls have you ever
been raped or have you ever been
subjected to domestic violence which are
very broad terms that have a lot of
stereotypes around them we instead asked
um you know many items
where we were quite factual and said you
know have you ever been strangled have
you ever been
thrown down some stairs have you ever
been kicked have you ever been sexually
touched without consent you know um and
i think that's
why the data is so much clearer in this
study
i mean even i mean going through some of
the details i mean even the figures of
being thrown down the stairs i mean that
sounds
extremely violent as far as i'm
concerned i mean even that figure was
pretty high wasn't it
yeah i think it was um 21
of women had been thrown down a flight
of stairs in childhood so before their
18th birthday
and i think it was around the same in
adulthood around 22 percent of women had
been thrown down a flight of stairs
um in adulthood so yeah i mean um
as you say even that is
probably quite a bit higher than what
people would expect but i think
it is down to method when you are clear
with people
when you remove ambiguity you get better
data
and obviously we were extremely lucky
that our sample size
was so huge as well i mean look but
you are looking at specificity by the
nature of this you're looking at
specific things whether it's
you know being hit in the face or being
spat on there are specifics here
but when you look at the overall sort of
picture of this
it is displaying a sort of a
sort of toxic childhood that a lot of
of young women and girls are going
through so how do we even begin to
address this what do you want to see
happen so the first thing i think that
we need
um as you said you know the statistics
in childhood and
adulthood especially for sexual violence
so
the examples you just brought up were in
in a section of the study around
physical violence but
um it was actually more common for women
and girls to be
sexually assaulted and sexually abused
in childhood and in adulthood
than it was physical assault so physical
assault sat you know sort of 30 50 60
percent
whereas sexual assaults and sexual abuse
in childhood sat at 80
82 87 and then in adulthood were
around the same um rapes were at one in
two and things like that so sexual
violence was actually more common than
physical
rapes were racist rapes were 50
yes so our statistics found that
i have it here i want to make sure that
i am accurate um
51 of women reported that they woke up
to their partners
having sex with them or performing sex
sex on them whilst they were asleep
so um and for the majority of women um
that had happened more than three times
in a relationship so that's male
partners
performing sex acts on them or actually
having penetrative sex with them whilst
they were sleeping they wake up and
that's happening
um and then further than that um
55 of adult women said that they had
been forced to have penetrative sex that
they'd said no to
so that's and again this is why instead
of saying rape
which a lot of women might not have said
yes to them i thought well it wasn't
really a rape maybe you know i wasn't
dragged off into some bushes by a
stranger
instead we made it very clear and yeah
absolutely it came out at one in two
heck it really is a shocking study um i
know you're sending it out to
to all mps it'd be interesting to see
what reaction we get from those over the
coming days dr taylor good to talk to
you thank you
thank you
now history is going to be made next
month when a ship
without any crew will become the first
powered by
artificial intelligence to cross the
atlantic it's all part of
the fight to tackle climate change our
science correspondent
thomas more reports from plymouth
cutting through the waters of plymouth
sound without any human control
the mayflower 400 is completely
autonomous
with an artificially intelligent
computer in charge and is about to
navigate three
thousand miles across some of the
world's busiest shipping lanes to
america
with satellite maps of nearby ships and
six onboard cameras
it can spot hazards and stay around them
so it's looking at all those positions
and then it's scanning 12 miles around
with its radar
and then it's looking with its cameras
and it's fusing it's like okay that
is a radar contact and that's a picture
of the thing i see on the radar
and it's got a beacon on it that i can
see through my satellites that says it's
this kind of ship and it's going this
fast in this direction
and then using the radar and the cameras
it sort of validates that it's like yep
that's that ship and it is doing what it
says it's doing
i have to turn or speed up or slow down
so that i obey the rules and cross
the right way without humans on board
there's no need for bunks
toilets or a kitchen it's pure machine
in future even cargo vessels are likely
to have an artificially intelligent
captain
that takes over out at sea but this is a
marine research ship
the ocean covers 70 percent of the
planet but just
five percent has been explored it's so
vast
that much of it is beyond the reach of
scientists
until now inside the hull
robotic instruments will test the sea
water climate change is making the
oceans warmer and more acidic
putting marine life under pressure
plankton the bottom of the food chain
will be monitored
and the ship will also listen to wales
to gauge how many there are in the open
ocean
the ocean impacts us all far more than
we may even realize you know it's not
just
the food that we eat it's our travel our
trade and above all it's our climate as
well the ocean regulates our planet to a
huge extent it also produces
half of the oxygen that we breathe so it
is it's
hugely vital we really need to up our
game
to start to have innovation like this
and take advantage of the technology
that's out there now
it should take around a fortnight to
cross the atlantic 400 years ago the
original mayflower took early settlers
to america
its namesake is another pioneer sailing
the seas on its own
to check the health of the ocean thomas
more sky news in plymouth
and of course you can watch our daily
climate show later on today
at half past six and at half past nine
here on sky news
now new figures have revealed that
around two million children in the uk
have been digitally excluded from their
own education
over the last year well of course what a
strange year it's been for
for all children but a lot of it's been
so reliant on internet access
now a host of prominent faces including
the former prime minister gordon brown
are calling for a new
digital inclusion strategy for
britain and uh gordon brown joins us now
good to see you this morning uh look
what actually can be done
in sort of urgent rapid terms to deal
with this
what get computers to children who don't
have them there's 400 000
they don't even have a laptop or any
form of computer
then there's two million people that
don't have access so you cut the charges
that parents have to pay
to get telecom access to the internet
you give
information free of charge across the
internet like educational and health
information
and you make sure that those people have
been excluded for more than a year
are now included i mean it seems
ridiculous that we're talking about this
uh nearly in may 15 months after the
pandemic started
and we haven't solved this problem we
can solve so many other problems
like getting a vaccine but we haven't
been able to solve this basic problem
getting computers and access to kids
whose education is really suffering
and will suffer for years if we don't do
something about this i mean
how much of this is is based on uh
you know an economic situation families
that cannot afford the internet cannot
afford computers
and how much of it is down to the fact
that you know
for a lot of parts of this country
internet access is
patchy at best well there's an offcom
report out this morning that says we've
got 94
access so that's not the biggest problem
we need to get to the last mile so to
speak
the biggest problem is that families
cannot afford the computers they cannot
afford to pay their
telecom charges there may be a number of
children in the family and they're all
competing for access to the one facility
and that means that some will lose out
and so you know we're talking
this morning about a digital uh passport
about the government making it possible
for people to digitally register and
everything else for going abroad
surely we can do something about the
poorest children in this country
and schools want this to happen teachers
want this to happen parents want this to
happen
really we need changes often new
regulations about social tariffs
new regulations about making sure that
information can travel free when it's
educational information
and of course making sure that children
have the computers themselves
we've got tim berners-lee the inventor
of the worldwide web this morning saying
this we've got martha lane fox
there used to be digital champions
saying this there's a chorus of people
saying
something really has to be done
how much of this is responsibility of
government do you think
i mean obviously some of it is but but
how much do we need
private business whether it's you know
manufacturers or whether it's broadband
providers
to actually step up and and have a sort
of
social responsibility here
yeah i i'm un special envoy for
education i've tried on numerous
occasions
to get all these companies together and
to work as one
but you know each of them wants their
own world garden they will give access
to certain people
and we've really got to get them all to
work together so we have different forms
of
reductions in prices offered by british
telecom and virgin and so on
it is so complicated that i think
parents will find it difficult to
understand it
so the way forward is for ofcom to say
come together
we will make it possible for a social
tariff to be introduced that means
cheaper prices for families let's say
families on universal credit
with children who really cannot afford
to pay these charges
if at the same time they're paying for
food clothes and everything else
i mean it's interesting with sir tim
berners-lee as you said the inventor of
the internet who's
who's turned around and said you know
internet access is now a human right now
i guess a lot of us could understand
that now but that's that's happened
quite quickly hasn't it that that
reliance on the internet
yes and it's happened particularly over
the last year but it benefits those
who've
got the money to pay for it and it
doesn't benefit those who haven't
and if we're serious about every child
having a the best possible chance
every school people getting access to
the educational information even if
they're not at school
then we really have to do something
about this and take it more seriously i
think the prime minister should chair
a digital task force that makes it
possible
for every child to be connected and get
schools involved in this as well so that
even if we have to return to some form
of
study at home but even if we don't we've
got access for these children at home
well you mentioned the prime minister
and it's not often we get to talk to
someone like you who's had so much
experience in
in number 10 and number 11. um look
what's your view on what's being what's
being said at the moment
and the questions over the the integrity
in downing street
well as you know i'd prefer to talk
about access to the digital
services and i would like to say
something about what's happening in
india
because something could be done about
that immediately but yes look
um it's pretty clear to me that three
things have got to happen if you're
going to have proper standards in public
life
you need a register of gifts so any
gifts the prime minister receives
got to be registered got to be made
public and so nobody is beholden to
anybody else
and gifts are all declared and clearly
there were gifts involved in the
refurbishment of this flag the second
thing is you need a register of
conflicts of interest
it's clear that there are downing street
officials who were in the private sector
doing other jobs
while at the same time being public
officials supposedly serving full time
in the public sector
that can't continue you need a register
of what's gone wrong
and you need to say look you're either
working for the
government of the public interest or
you're working for a private company you
can't do both here
and i think the third thing you've got
to really be
careful about is is obviously people
reporting
uh their lobbying activities i mean if
the prime minister is lobbied
for a commercial interest he's got to
report it and so there should be a
register of lobbying
that makes it absolutely clear who was
talking to whom about certain things
including
over the telephone because we cannot
have this impression growing that
some people have got access to
government and other people don't it
just seems completely unfair
there are millions of people around this
country at the moment who want to say
something
about something that's wrong they want
sorted out by the prime minister they
don't get this access
but some privileged people do one law
for an elite
one law for the rest it's simply not
fair
i mean during your time in number 10 and
in number 11 i mean there must have been
people that you were having contact with
people who had access
to you because they were running a a
huge corporation or
or whatever it may be i mean they end up
because of that having a louder voice
don't they
well you meet people but then you report
that you've met them what seems to be
happening here is that
there's private conversations going on
on the internet or going on in
telephones and they're not properly
reported you need to register all this
in the public interest everything has
got to be seen to be above board
and no prime minister no minister should
be seen to be beholden
to someone who gives him money for this
or for that
or who's got special access for one
reason or another
that's all going to be above board
otherwise people will lose faith
and lose trust in the way the political
systems work and i fear that scandal
is going to follow this government as
long as it is in power
unless it does something to clean up its
act look should
in in your opinion and and it's great to
talk to you now that you're you're
you're away from all the the big offices
of state
because you think you've been because
because you can be well look you can be
a bit more frank can't you can be a bit
more straightforward about this with
with comments that the
attributed to the prime minister around
the pandemic and let the bodies pile
high let it rip i mean
it's denied that it is said but when
you're in number 10 when you're
in a meeting behind closed doors
presumably
yeah as prime minister you are much more
frank about what's going on you would
say
things would you that that you wouldn't
expect to be repeated
anywhere else yeah but this is a matter
of public policy i mean i think what
people are really asking
was that really the prime minister's
view and was he
slow in uh undertaking a lockdown
because
that was what he felt so i think he's
got to clarify it
this is not just your private comments
about an individual
or about some event that has happened
this is about
public policy and i think you've got to
be honest and open with the government
if that was your view let's
let's hear that that was your view and
then you change your view but
i think there's got to be some honesty
when it comes to the saving of lives
look
look this morning you know there are a
million cases
of kobe being reported every day now
there's a hundred thousand people dying
a week in india
four hundred 000 people they suspect uh
have died
and and it's 15 months into this
pandemic and surely we can get the
equipment the oxygen the vaccinations
to all the people in the world because
nobody is safe until everyone's safe
and these are the issues that i think
the prime minister should be directing
his attention to today
okay well justin just in 30 seconds
because we're almost off air but
because you've pointed that out and it
is important as you say do you think
these other issues are
at the moment at least a distraction
i i think what we've got to talk about
is saving lives but we've got to have
good standards of government as well and
i'm interested in this morning in
getting an agreement between all the
countries
that can make sure that everybody is
safe because we do something about the
spread of the disease
the mutation forgive me forgive me for
butting in but what should what should
saqir be focusing on then
oh zakir will focus on i think getting
to the truth of what's been happening
because
we need to know what the truth is okay
gordon brown
really good to talk to you this morning
thank you very much indeed
all the headlines coming up just a
moment